how do we help people directly
prop if you're going to have to pay for
it
and you don't want it to come out of the
trust fund
once something could be a rebate card or
a direct payment and those are the
things that are being considered
those are the things that are being
considered senator tom cotton joins me
now
senator
perhaps it's because of their advanced
age or something but biden and pelosi do
not seem to care very much about
america's future
no laura they don't you know nancy
pelosi is talking about gimmicks i would
call what joe biden has proposed to
gimmick but it's much worse than that
it's dangerous the strategic petroleum
reserve is for emergencies the only
emergency i see is joe biden's polling
numbers and the fact that we've got a
midterm coming up in about seven months
but if we release this oil from the
strategic petroleum reserve every day
for the next six months we're only
treating the symptoms not the cause
its cause is the war that joe biden is
waging on oil and gas production in
america in 2019 at the peak of
production under the last administration
we're producing more than a million
barrels every single day than we're
producing today so that alone is what
he's releasing from the strategic
petroleum reserve if we would simply
allow
the oil and gas workers across america
to produce the resources that god put
underneath our soil
but it's worse than that
what if say iran emboldened by a
terrible nuclear deal strikes refineries
or production facilities in places like
saudi arabia or kuwait or the united
arab emirates what if a major hurricane
hits louisiana and texas this year
that's why we have the strategic
petroleum reserve not to float joe
biden's terrible poll numbers and try to
help the democrats limp into a midterm
election this is not just a gimmick it's
dangerous well one democrat doesn't seem
interested senator in lowering gas
prices
the one consumer product that
each american knows uh is the price of
gasoline uh and it becomes a metaphor
for the economy which is why it's
imperative that we announce a green new
deal agenda that's the message which i'm
working with and that's the message
which joe biden is is uh making very
clear has to be the agenda for our
country
senator is this proof democrats just
want americans to suffer in order to
push through this green agenda i mean
amazing yeah god i know god bless ed
markey he tells the truth and it is the
truth joe biden said this in the
campaign five dollar gallon gas is not
an accident it's not an unintended
consequence it is the intended
consequence of their energy policies
they want to make us all poorer they
want to make you live in downtown areas
and high-rise buildings and walk to work
or take the subway or ride an electric
scooter or whatever it is that pete buda
judge takes to work this week they want
to get you out of your pickup truck out
of your suv out of your home in the
suburbs where you can have a backyard
with your kids this is the exactly
intended consequences of their energy
policies they don't like it now though
that it's going to cost them control of
the united states congress this fall and
i want to move to the crush at the
southern border senator um which is only
going to get worse once title 42 is
repealed that allowed for the immediate
expulsion of people who cross the border
here was the white house today
you have said many many times obviously
this is a decision that the cdc will
make
that said of course we are preparing for
contingencies
and so what i would say is
you know our goal is going to be to
process migrants in a safe and orderly
manner
a safe and orderly manner to a work site
near you
right
yeah you know laura how about our goal
be that we protect our border and we not
allow two million illegal aliens to come
in
this year this is not a decision for the
cdc it is the decision for the president
he could direct them to keep that
emergency order in place just as they've
kept the emergency order in place for
toddlers wearing masks and airplanes for
everyone
there's
there's an emergency on airplanes in
america but there's not an emergency at
our southern border this just another
example of how democrats love to use
covid when it suits their goals whether
it allows them to admit more illegal
aliens into the country or they running
around congress right now saying they
need 16 billion dollars more in
emergency covet funding but when it's
inconvenient to them like i don't know
joe biden's approval numbers or gavin
newsom having to go to a fancy french
restaurant they want to wish it away
well senator really quickly it looks
like there could be as many as four to
five million people crossing our
southern border
this year the way things are going 18
000 a day now but that's only going to
ramp up that's just in the eagle pass
district bill mollusion was reporting
i mean or 1800 today i want to make sure
i get the number right but it's it's
more than we've ever seen ever in the
history of the country
that's staggering
it's unprecedented it's terrible for
america's workers it's terrible for our
families and communities because so many
drugs are going to be coming across our
border as well if joe biden wants a dime
of additional spending then he should uh
then we should get a vote next week in
the united states congress on keeping
this emergency order in place so we can
at least keep some
some element of control on the border no
matter how tiny it is under this
president hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else